a Canadian performance at the NBA's
All-Star Weekend in Salt Lake City is
getting a lot of attention Toronto's
Julie black sang our national anthem but
her rendition changed a key word in the
song referencing Canada's Colonial Roots
take a listen Julie I watched this video
a few times I just noticed right now
though that you looked right at the
camera when you said it so let me start
by asking you how did this come about
was it pre-planned
yeah so a few days before I was leaving
for Utah I I just felt this I just felt
an impressed on my heart that I needed
to do something different and that would
take the light off of me in fact I have
indigenous friends I ran it by them one
in particular Roy Perot who's a great
friend and we worked together and he
felt good about it and I just needed at
least one trustworthy cosign and I went
with it
now you've sang the national anthem
countless times Canadians have heard you
why did you decide this was the moment
to change that keyword
well this is a global stage for the for
the Canadian national anthem like if you
think about it the Super Bowl is the
next biggest the biggest stage just in
the anthem and Canada isn't represented
there even though there are Canadian
football players whole other thing and
so I've turned the anthem down over the
years since 2020 with all that's going
on with indigenous rights and Truth and
Reconciliation I didn't feel that I was
prepared to stand behind the words but
having this opportunity having this
privilege as being Julie black being
chosen it was time for me to do
something there and and educate educate
to elevate it's kind of like if you know
you know to the Americans but all of
Canada knew
what kind of feedback have you been
getting
it's been beautifully positive
um there's the other trolls the trolls
actually make me laugh because these
keyboard gangsters I'm like come on come
on stop it the truth is I didn't in my
heart I didn't change the words of the
anthem the song The Anthem wasn't
correctly written to begin with so this
is what needs to happen it's a rewrite
hmm that's interesting do you want to
see this happen formally do you want to
see discussions for it to be formally
changed to happen
100 fairer I can't sing it the old way
and I'm not saying that it has to be
exact like you know changed completely
every single word but I think that with
a song that has so much history it's
important for us who are on today like
this is a new Time new generation to
really listen to it and say huh it's
like the Bible I read my phone could I
stand behind the scripture like someone
told me this scripture now I gotta learn
for myself same thing with this Anthem
that's how I'm treating it let me let me
really take these words in and see if I
could stand behind all of them
Julie black singing the anthem for the
first time since 2020 and changing the
words thanks so much for your time